so the headlines read that remington is
subpoenaing the student records of the
first graders who were shot and killed
in the sandy hook massacre so i assume
that in this litigation remington issued
a very broad discovery request something
along the lines of all documents related
to the children and someone blew it out
of the proportion by saying oh they're
specifically requesting educational
records which have no relevance actually
not so and the headlines are actually
pretty accurate here i took a look at
the actual discovery requests which read
any and all educational records in your
possession including but not limited to
application admission paperwork
attendance records transcripts report
cards disciplinary records
correspondence and any and all other
educational information and records
pertaining to each of the five first
graders at issue so yeah those are
actually much more specific than i
thought and it's hard to see what kind
of relevance those documents would have
in this particular litigation and so as
a result the plaintiff's lawyers are
trying to get a protective order to
prevent the disclosure of those records
related to the first grade children who
were killed in that case and they
probably stand a pretty good chance of
quashing that subpoena but we'll see
what happens in court